eight days after Hurricane Maria
flattened much of Puerto Rico basic
resources like food water fuel and
medicine are still hard to find supplies
have arrived but they're not getting
delivered to the 3.4 million American
citizens on the island the lack of power
and communication is hindering relief
efforts officials say more than 91
percent of Puerto Rico's cellphone sites
are out of service David Berg no is
outside a gas station in San Juan where
people are desperate for fuel David good
morning it's been a week since the
hurricane made landfall and these are
Americans sitting in line sleeping in
their car desperately trying to get fuel
that lady was here when they ran out she
was almost at the front of the line this
family right here slept in their car and
they've been waiting since 9:00 a.m.
yesterday this is the gas station in San
Juan where everybody's flocking to they
ran out of fuel here about 6 o'clock
local time last night and they're going
to get another shipment today but
they're running out every day officials
have told us the local Children's
Hospital here in San Juan is going to
run out of diesel if they don't get more
by new again this morning more than 3000
shipping containers are sitting at the
port of San Juan in these containers we
have medicines there's water Jose Ayala
is vice president of Crowley shipping
services Puerto Rico
he says the stalled supplies could help
more than a half million Puerto Ricans
it's maddening to look out here and see
it sitting knowing that there are people
desperate for food and water
yeah it's that and it's frustrating as
well unless trucking companies start
showing up unfortunately there is
nothing that we can do the governor
Ricardo Rose AO told us there's a
shortage of truck drivers to deliver the
essentials the bus drivers that would
traditionally take these foods they
don't they're not a pyramid you can't
find them you can't reach them you can't
find out more reach them most roads are
still blocked by debris and fuel is in
very short supply lines still stretch
for a 1/2 mile or more as people wait in
the stifling heat for basic necessities
gas to power generators this is our
third day getting gas it's
with the tanks they just hold so very
little just one gallon two gallon five
gallons it's just not enough it's very
bad it is horrible and we are we're
American citizens we're not better than
anyone but we're not worse than anyone
David beg no in San Juan